and by the power of castle hate skull i
am hella mark harley and today
we have some controversial topics to
cover on the haters will say podcast
will we get into tom cruise ssris
antidepressants depression itself and
the science behind it unfolding before
our very eyes because
this is a podcast not only about fitness
but also about the adjacent topics
related to fitness
if fitness is the bottom of the food
pyramid you know that's such a bad
analogy because the food pyramid was
debunked right remember it was like eat
18 servings of grains every day well
turns out that's not the best advice
eating four baguettes a day
unless you're french and have that
french baguette gene that requires you
to eat that many baguettes every day
it's just not a viable solution to
long-term health so
let me let me backtrack and say
if
if fitness is the ground level
then psychological health is the the
chair that i sit in right now can we say
that
it's supporting me but underneath that
right the the floor is supporting the
chair
and the chair is supporting these
luscious ass cheeks
which i can see because you're wearing
the new thickness right yeah if you
didn't see it just want to take a little
peek right now what's going on here
they're so short that you can uh-huh and
they're swim trunks
but they don't feel stiff like swim
trunks all right
they feel like something you could work
out and however yes there are webbing uh
there's webbing around my balls right
now i'll just say that okay it's a
hybrid so it keeps those
it keeps those plums nice and safe but
also keeps those thighs moving freely
worked out in them yesterday felt great
testes felt supported what's left of
them
now
i wanted to start off today with
a lot of people been asking me before we
even get to sup full because so many
people have been asking me things and
then i get to backtrack and say whoa
whoa whoa let's cover this because
an ounce of a lot of people been asking
me can cure a pound of annoying dms no
you're not annoying me but you know what
people do ask questions
and sometimes i go i like i want to have
a longer conversation i want if you if
you message me
something to the effect of how do you
get in shape i want you to get in shape
i want everybody to learn but it's such
a complicated nuanced thing because
there's so many ways to hate to use the
analogy but skin that cat right who
skins cats these days certainly not me
and i don't even like thinking about it
but
there's so many ways to do it and it's
such a wide-ranging conversation that
boils down to a few basic
principles somebody asked me the other
day
you know
seems like a young person i didn't go
too much into it let's go to the
screenshots right now okay i'm gonna say
this
i posted this to my story got a little
bit of feedback on it that wasn't so
great other people thought it was funny
but
the guy says bruh i've never lifted
before idk where to start
is there a workout plan you suggest for
beginners it's not the most annoying
message i've ever received but
it's so broad and it makes me think you
know if i was able to find a way to get
steroids off the internet delivered to
my college dorm room in 2001 how are you
not figuring out how to get a workout
split in 2022 from youtube
you have so many more resources is that
apples and oranges i don't know but it
makes me think this
i go have you ever searched lifting
program for beginners in youtube
i will help you regardless i just wanted
to know how little curiosity you have
now that's maybe slightly dickish but
that's kind of how i feel however he's
framing it like you know he came back i
think and said something to the effect
of
um
you know there's just a lot of
information out there which is true i
just maybe it's a reflection on me if i
get a little frustrated or annoyed it's
because i don't have an easy answer to
that and sometimes when you know it it's
like a parent you know well what does
that mean and you're like no not for i
said you know why am i supposed to go to
school because i said so you find
yourself snapping right
so last night i was a snapping turtle
now i posted that to my story
and i asked out his name so as not to
shame him and my little caption was okay
but first just how ignorant are you but
it is an important question i have to
know if you're asking me these uh things
i have to like how little do you know
where are we starting you know have you
ever lifted a weight before because more
than just a program it's like how are
you going to implement that program so
that's part of what i cover in the next
thing
a guy messages me and says what's crazy
is that guy looks up to you and would
rather hear your pointers than youtube's
that could be true and i feel honored
and privileged anytime somebody does
come to me
and seek me out for whatever reason
right you're coming to me you're not
coming to somebody else you're not going
to youtube or any other expert
although i'm not an expert i just know
some stuff this makes you look like a
dick and idk what's the deal with idk
idk if that's your gig or not you lost a
fan here i'm unsubscribing and
unfollowing
i feel like you might not have been a
fan if if that tone is the first thing
you've ever seen from me in which i'm
using sarcasm
or a slightly edgy language
i said well then you would have a fan to
begin with i have every right to ask
someone who's asking for free help on a
subject they seemingly have zero desire
to investigate on their own whether or
not they actually have zero curiosity
because that's the difference between
someone i can point in the right
direction
and
using their intelligence and curiosity
can thrive and on the other hand
someone who is expecting me to hold
their hand spend hours breaking down
every bit of advice to simpler more
digestible nuggets and who ultimately
lacks the drive to do anything
substantial alone right because that's
always the important factor
you know
are you going to be reliant on someone
your entire life okay then hire a
trainer
right
somehow i figured this out on my own and
a lot of people i know who are advanced
lifters
they had the curiosity they had the
drive and not to judge other people i
know there's going to be a small
percentage of the people who actually
have that drive to do it on their own
and don't need any help or can pick up
things by
looking and just going to the gym and
showing up and that's a different
personality type maybe you feel a little
more insecure maybe you whatever you're
more
you're more hesitant you're not as extra
whatever the case may be whatever those
personality factors might be that would
lead to you being a little bit more
cautious about going to the gym because
a lot of people i sometimes forget are
embarrassed about showing up and not
knowing what to do
i don't have that and it's hard for me
to even remember a time that i did
although i'm sure it was the case
because you just don't know i remember
other
like bigger guys at the gym trying to
you know i remember looking at them and
thinking oh they must be thinking
negatively about me or even in some
cases directly correcting you on certain
things and feeling like i don't like
that feeling because it feels
condescending and so i try not to do
that to other people like if it's not
solicited help
um
so
i'm gonna help this guy i'm going to
pass on some stuff i'm going to break it
down in simple terms it's just
you know
i had a guy
actually message me the other day as i
mentioned in the last episode i believe
where i wasn't sure if he was trolling
me or not he sent me
you know he asked for advice in his
deadlift he sent me a pic video of it he
was dead lifting 225 his back was
rounding like you needed to cut that in
half
send me back send me a weight that you
can do with absolute perfect form and he
did he sent me a video with 135 i was
like that is amazing
uh you look good doing that use that
form
keep going up in weight in small
increments five ten pounds until you
can't anymore right and that's your
limit and progressively overload from
there don't be in a rush
to put on 100 pounds on your deadlift
when you're 16 years old
in the next few months but think about
it mathematically if you were to put on
two and a half pounds a week that's 10
pounds a month that's 120 pounds in a
year so
i said you could probably based on how
easily you did that 135 you could
probably do 185 pounds right now
and in a year's time you can do
300 or more for reps
if
you keep that same form and do it the
smart way and take your time and have
longevity in mind
rather than trying to rush things and
blowing out your back in the process now
a friend of mine diego
diego curry probably the only
friend um
i've had outside of like meeting some
new people recently gold's gym who's a
competitive bodybuilder
diego courier
my caption on this was diego carrera
maybe a complete [ __ ] that's hater
saying that not me and an even bigger
bully than me but god damn it if he
doesn't know bodybuilding sort of an
inside joke between us but
his recommendation and he knows his
stuff
he says i think you're better off doing
the following if you're a beginner
squat deadlift pull-up bench press
military press three days per week
for the first four to eight weeks
then an upper body lower body split for
four to eight weeks and then after that
an actual efficient split i like that i
like that as beginner advice because
when i look back to my training now i
enjoyed doing a bro split where you do
like chest one day or you know chest and
biceps or your chest and biceps and then
back and triceps and then
shoulders
and legs or something you know there was
a point when i was like 16 or i was
working out six days a week and all the
muscles were getting hit like that and i
worked out like that for a few months
and then i remember getting over trained
and kind of being sick because that is a
lot
my workouts are long i'd be doing 30
plus
30 plus sets per workout
it eventually catches up with you but i
made some good progress in there
looking back on it i would focus more of
my energy in mastering the basics and at
that point because you're not that
strong
you're getting a lot of stimulus
per the fatigue that you're
inducing
if you're super strong and you're
squatting 500 pounds for reps you're
accumulating a gigantic level of fatigue
maybe you're hitting you know a level of
stimulus on the target areas like your
quads for example
um there's a certain level of stimulus
obviously but
is that better served perhaps by a
deadlift or sorry a leg extension or a
leg press because you can really target
the muscle that you're trying to
overload without
fatiguing and potentially injuring these
weak links like your lower back or if
you have any lingering injuries you know
like i have a groin injury that's
lingering
that could come up when you're doing
those heavy compound lifts however if
you're doing 135
the fatigue that you're accumulating
versus the stimulus is in your favor
so you get the additional practice you
get the favorable stimulus to fatigue
ratio
you get to get really good at those
exercises and because you're a newbie
right
the average person isn't going to be
able to increase their military press
you know if you've been lifting for five
or ten years
that is the
slowest compound movement to go up
however when you're an absolute beginner
you could be going up really fast or do
it three times a week do the squat three
times a week do the deadlift do the pull
up and then away to pull up etc you can
actually go up
really quickly and then when that slows
down you accommodate your split
in a way that makes sense
okay so that's one way to do it and
somebody else just asked me they
actually
messaged me to be like
brendan was rude in the food truck
diaries i'm like oh interesting
i was there watching it with chandler he
was like
uh you know he came off as really
dismissive like what are you talking
about but i asked in politics like oh
interesting what do you mean and he was
like oh about the adoption stuff and i
was like okay yeah i guess i'll have to
check it out
um
and
he's like yeah all good and then he
pivoted immediately too hey i'm trying
to get in shape i'm like wait a second
and i feel like people do that a lot to
me but it's okay like i get it it's like
okay hey now that i have your attention
uh
what do you eat for breakfast
but that would be a much easier question
to answer than the question you did hit
me with which is like i'm getting
married in eight months and i want to
get in shape
what should i do essentially
there's so many questions you know how
much time do you have how much time do
you want to spend in the gym uh what
kind of stuff have you done before what
are you good at what are your injuries
this is the reason that personal
trainers if they're any good and i'm
learning this it's like oh god i have to
have this ready-made diagnostic form
otherwise we're talking on the phone
but you got to answer all those
questions so if you decide to message me
i guess this is what i'm really getting
at give me as much information as
possible it's okay people get
self-conscious about writing me longer
messages but i actually
the more information you give me as far
as your workout history your time
restraints your experience level that
allows me to get really specific right
off the bat and spend less time giving
you an answer which incentivizes me to
actually
give you an answer right because if it's
too broad and i have to ask you too many
questions and wait for you to go back
you know there's just more opportunities
for the whole thing to unravel
but in that case if i was looking for an
efficient
way to get in shape in eight months i'd
do circuits you know i'd spend half an
hour
three to five times a week
doing high intensity circuits i just
think if you're not trying to put on a
bunch of muscle
or you're not trying to just lose weight
as rapidly as possible because it's like
yeah starve yourself and run marathons
if that's the only objective is to lose
weight but if you want some element of
body recomp you have a real job
do these circuits that i always talk
about such as uh you know take a pair of
dumbbells for me that might be
you know let's say
80 90 pound hundred pound dumbbells
i'm doing flatter incline dumbbell bench
with them i'm standing up to bent over
rows with them i'm doing rdls
i'm either doing a goblet squat with one
um
or
lunging with them
or
taking both on my shoulders which is
pretty hard you know that could be hard
to balance and but the weight's still
good you don't have to do that high reps
and then maybe you're taking the weight
laying on a bench and doing like a
pullover into a crunch right you got to
push you got to pull you got a hinge you
got a squat you got an ab boom and your
heart rate's up do that for three rounds
simple formula repeat that on a barbell
on dumbbells a machine's um body weight
right dips pull ups crunches
uh jumping squats and lunges
and maybe you'll add in a kettlebell
swing right it's hard to hinge uh
overload a hinge motion with your own
body weight
but if you have one kettlebell you can
do amazing things with the full body
circuit okay does that answer your
question and then that parlays me into
something else that i'm going to preview
for you guys yesterday we shot some
sketches with zach holmes he's in the
new jackass movie i believe he was on
chappelle's podcast we'd
seen each other around the internet i
was familiar with this stuff
uh he followed me a couple years back we
have some mutual friends
and
uh
you probably have seen him
break his ankle on the skateboard have
you seen that clip where he like
does the tib fib you know clean break
oh god it's horrifying but
you know
also very ballsy to then put that out on
the internet because i've broken my
ankle before it was like the tiniest
fracture and i was screaming like a
little girl at the time i was a little
girl i actually transitioned into a boy
shortly after that
to leave that former life of whininess
upon broken bones behind but
i can say i wouldn't want that going
viral on the internet is all i'm saying
i did break my ankle skateboarding
doing a board side off something about
yay tall
but that's the deal you can fall off
something super low and if your ankle is
at the right angle it's going to snap if
you're 300 pounds it's going to snap
really hard
so
we shot some sketches yesterday some
promos for thick boy
and
we started texting back and forth and he
was like hey man
you know i want to lose some weight i
want to get healthy again
uh he's going to come on this show i
asked him
because we started talking i really
wanted to help him because my guess
you know typical stuff it's like hey i
lost a bunch of weight before here's me
my skinniest i used to do the chicken
vegetables
only diet and that really worked but
it's like we're gonna do eat chicken and
vegetables for the rest of your life i
think a lot of people don't know how to
get out of that
mode and into something that's more
sustainable and enjoyable and people
think you can't even eat sauces right
you kind of get obsessive and
you know that can be good there's
nothing wrong with short-term obsession
i think but especially with when it
comes to weight loss and there's so much
you know there's hormonal activity going
on
the hunger hormones leptin ghrelin we
covered before if you're really fat
those things might be
out of order right if you've been fat
for a really long time
um
that hormone that makes you feel full
leptin you could be totally desensitized
to that so you just never feel full
right
because you know other people my size
not my size probably a little bit
smaller but you know you could be
muscular and still say
you know to eat as much as mark is i
feel like i'm force-feeding myself and
i'm eating something and i still feel
hungry because ultimately it's a hormone
leads to a feeling right
have a bunch of testosterone or trend
and you're horny it's a feeling
you know it's not making you do anything
but it's giving you this impulse this
impulse to eat this impulse to
uh [ __ ] your sock with vaseline in it
oh my god just just as a crazy example
um
you know but
i talked to zach about coming on the
show cause i was like you know what
would be really cool
we agreed to talk about doing a
diagnostic
you know on the phone because that's
because i don't have that all written
down it's kind of easy for me to do it
this way
and he was like yeah you know that'd be
cool
we could do this weekend and they said
hey what if you come on the show and we
kind of do it like on the show
it's going to be vulnerable for him
because we're not preparing anything and
i'm going to ask him questions about
what are your pitfalls what's your
history what's the kind of
psychology behind what you think your
problems are and figure that out because
i think that's so important
is figuring out where do you go wrong
but also what are some things that you
enjoy how can we tease out this notion
of like exercise has to be painful and
punishing and the diet has to be
bare bones and stoic and make me hate
eating right i think that's difficult
for obese people because there's so many
ingrained patterns and the relationship
with food is difficult i mean you know
i'm just slightly fat and my
relationship with food is difficult
did i get a lot fatter this weekend yes
i did but that's something that i'm
trying to recover from right now okay
i know this totally tight oak and stone
shirt isn't doing me any favors as far
as hiding that but you know what i'm
putting it out there because i'm
vulnerable too
so if you would like to see
me and zack talk it out
figure it out and then maybe do some
workouts
after that some more haters will say
training vlogs
drop a
like yeah in the comments okay
now so although tom cruise does
disapprove of the use of ritalin ssris
and adderall
he's actually a big proponent of happy
hippo kratom and all the other products
available at
happyhippoherbles.com and when he buys
from
happyhippoherbles.com he makes sure to
use
thick boy with three c's as a promo code
to get 20 off and you're probably
thinking mark tom cruise is a
millionaire why would he use any sort of
promo code well the truth is a good deal
is a good deal and how do you think he
stays a millionaire right
yeah exactly
he's cutting down at his starbucks he
only gets one latte they used to do two
um avocado toast only twice a month and
he uses the promo code thickboy at
happyhippourbales.com
he's rich he's not stupid
and once again i'm here to combat the
persistent rumors that oakenstone just
makes luxurious clothing for people who
are going out on a first date and trying
to make an amazing impression
on
the opposite sex in this case a hot girl
who's going to be very impressed by the
fact that you're wearing a nice oak and
stone shirt
there's a rumor going around that just
won't die that mark that's great and all
but like what about day to day stuff
what if you're just in
athletic shorts with a dope ass
backwards hat
you can't possibly pair oak and stone
with that combo can you well the fact is
you can and i'm proving that right now
because i've got an oak and stone shirt
on
i've got a backwards cap no cap
and also i've got the thick boy shorts
on hugging the old thighs
looking great it's a fresh summer look
whether you're 16 years old or 19 like
me
it's all the same you're gonna look cool
you're gonna look fresh you're gonna
impress the ladies at the pool party
that's coming up of this weekend so be
there or be square
you're gonna look great in oak and stone
and that's fair
i wanted to also talk about something
that i thought was interesting i don't
know how much you guys are involved in
the world of fitness drama
but in this section called hella fitness
drama
we are going to talk a little bit about
something that happened recently because
there's a deeper point big boy
strength cartel this is a dude who's a
big player in the fitness game
supplements he's got
uh merch he's got he's also an
accomplished power lifter
he's uh a big tattered he's got like one
of the widest frames i've ever seen like
he's just a gigantic dude he says he's
270 but my guess
would be he's more like 300 pounds at 5
10 5 11. and actually there's a funny
video of eric knefsky
uh going up to him at the
a recent uh
fitness convention and asking him you
have you seen these videos where ed
knesset goes up to bodybuilders he's
like how much you weigh in these days
and they're like oh about 260 and he's
like
here's a scale step on it
or you know like you'll go up to a
bodybuilder like how tall are you and
they're like five nine and he's like can
we measure you
which is like
it's funny but it's also disrespectful
so he had this uh confrontation
with big boy and big boy's friendly at
first
and eric caneski just kept putting now
ericknowski's a pretty big dude you know
probably in the high 200s himself very
muscular and he's
he's an amazing troll i don't think he's
scared of big boy you know big boy is
very big very athletic he can do some
pretty incredible things
as far as lifting but also like can do
like 360 kick flips and [ __ ] like it's
you know he moves like a much smaller
guy so he's dangerous obviously
but arkansas was like in his face and
these he just kept pressing he's like
you know he's like oh i'm 270 i'm 511
he's like can we measure he's like no
i'm good man i just want to keep it
respectful and he goes
what did i say it was disrespectful
he's like nothing i just you know but
like they kept kind of going back and
forth on that stalemate now
i'm kind of with big boy in this where
it's like you know you don't have the
right to like clap your hands and make
me jump on a scale
i don't care because it's not a
sensitive issue for me but if it was at
all
or if i had any sort of prior
relationship even just with erikanewski
content you know because he has a troll
and tries to make fools out of people in
a somewhat lighthearted way he also does
this like to catch a predator stuff
which is pretty
you know
i guess it's a good service to humanity
it also makes for some pretty good
content but
you know i think there's both sides of
the argument where
if you're going to make a claim and
you're at a fitness expo it might be a
little bit normal and i wouldn't mind
doing it because i think it's fun
because i'd be like you know my guess is
i'm what 250 let's actually see my guess
is i'm six three who knows maybe i'm
seven feet tall i just i tend to
undersell that because i don't want the
nba thinking i'm seven feet tall because
uh
people over seven feet tall short of
careers so there's that it's just
financially it's a better decision for
me to say that
so
there was a guy joey stacks and
the most roundabout way to ever say this
joey stacks was in the strength cartel
and came out and had a number of
accusations
against big boy he was being underpaid
he was being disrespectful like he was
talking [ __ ] about all the people in the
strength cartel behind his back and just
basically calling this guy a liar a
fraud
his merch is cheap he underpays people
he lies to people
uh there's this story about
big boy robbing rich piana back in the
day
and it starts off with joey stack saying
oh yeah we first met at this fitness
convention and started talking about
going to prison they both went to prison
when they were younger
and joey stacks was like oh yeah i was
in prison for a total of six years three
years on and they got caught
went back for three years
and big boy goes oh yeah i was in for
eight
and it turns out he was actually in
there for three
and he's like this was the start of me
realizing that he has to one-up
everybody and lie about stupid things
and that's an interesting psychological
phenomenon in and of itself people who
one-up and just can't like let something
go where it's like you know oh yeah
bench 200 history oh it's crazy i betcha
250 and it's like
what like
orson's like nobody's even like they'll
be on the side of the conversation and
be like yeah i bet it's 250 and it's
like but nobody asks you
or they'll insert things right that
don't even have even to do with
one-upping it's just like one-upping the
attention in the room you know the focus
on somebody else and you're like hey
this crazy thing happened and i'm really
awesome
right all stories kind of lead down that
road
there's a lot of
big boy's personality that makes me
think that's very possible that he's a
pathological liar because he leads so
much with charisma
when you see him on camera he's very
you're very drawn and he's an amazing
speaker he's very smooth you can see
that he knows how to make other people
feel good and trust him
and
he knows how to praise people like in
front of the camera or in front of them
and kind of build other people up and
make himself seem
sort of benevolent and selfless and i've
noticed that's what people who
um
true sociopaths that i've had in my life
have that gift where it's like they will
talk to you and make your brain tingle
with excitement
by making you feel special right that's
really the power it's not like they're
convincing you how awesome they are
of course they'll slip up and kind of
they don't realize sometimes how this
one upping or the bragging the subtle
bragging can come across but the main
gift that sucks people in is like
they're going to make you feel really
awesome the love bombing aspect of it
have you ever met somebody like that
casey
like somebody who later found out was
like a really bad person but at first
you're like oh this person like
is so nice i don't think so maybe it's
me maybe that's why i didn't [ __ ]
notice
no i don't think so uh yeah and you know
i try not to talk to people in general
so right statistically pretty rare and
i'm thinking like if i remove these you
know xyz people
because if you have emotional
intelligence it's also a red flag you
know like this like
it could be very charming but then
if you know anything you're kind of like
the moment somebody like one-ups you or
gives you that weird like you know vibe
of like
are they lying right now about something
totally arbitrary and irrelevant yeah we
had a guy i worked with once i mean we
called him the topper but he wasn't like
he wasn't a sociopath he was just like
it was just a topper insecure yeah yeah
yeah yeah cause that's another thing
it's like you don't have to you don't
have to be a sociopath to be a
pathological liar those two things tend
to correlate but you can also be
somebody who just
feels like
to be valued at a friend group you have
to embellish right and i have a lot of
sympathy for that i don't have a lot of
sympathy for people who use that
embellishment or lying or exaggeration
to then exploit other people right that
crosses a major line obviously
now
joey stacks put out this video leaving
strength cartel calling big boy out
big boy's response to that was to travel
to this fitness convention that you knew
that he knew joey stacks would be at in
texas
and try to fight him
joey stacks is much smaller now he's a
muscular dude but let's say he's like
five six five seven one seventy one
eighty max you know
big boy is a thing squats eight hundred
pounds you know like dead lifts like
seven plates for reps he's gigantic and
like you know like again has
like the the widest shoulders i've ever
seen at a human potentially now he's his
body fat's a little higher but like if
you could strip it all off he'd look
like
freakishly proportioned just how big he
is and he trains boxing he's fast and
athletic he could do some damage to a
guy who he's a hundred pounds more than
in a street fight
but
the code of the street is you call me
out you say my name you talk [ __ ] we're
fighting right so he shows up in this
hotel lobby and it's basically like
let's throw hands right now and joey
stacks is like you're 270 pounds
probably 300 but he kept saying you're
270. joey stacks takes out a knife
there's a confrontation there's drama
people are filming it yadda yadda he
puts it online
and the title of big boy big boy's video
is exposing joey stacks right because he
wouldn't fight him in the middle of a
hotel lobby now
i was like oh the comments must be
roasting big boy for like
having this angry
confrontational like physical
confrontation to somebody who's making
all these accusations of empirical facts
about you right if somebody was like
mark
you're a pathological liar and a shitty
human and you manipulate and exploit
people
my response wouldn't be i'm gonna beat
you up now to prove that i'm actually a
good person
that's just my logic but i guess the
logic of the street stick takes it
doesn't matter how big you are or
whatever if you
impugn somebody's name
you get your ass beat and because joey
stacks back down from that or pulled out
a knife or said i'm not going to fight
you he lost the argument
and also these are people on joey or
sorry on big boy's page so they're
biased towards agreeing with him but i'd
be very interested to know what you guys
think of this because it just struck me
as like hmm
you know he's calling out your entire
existence and you're like fight me
okay
and then you're just gonna be an [ __ ]
who bullies smaller people
tell me what you think because i'm
confused about this like how how logical
do you think this street element is
hella sick fitness page i'm gonna do
this real quick andrew huberman if you
haven't heard of him
check him out i just wanted to say
brendan was talking about being dizzy
the other day after not eating all day
and i happen to go upon a video
where he's talking about electrolytes
the importance of
sodium potassium and magnesium right
those are the three electrolytes
that regulate hydration in your body if
you don't have the proper electrolyte
balance if you have too much water
that's why people who consume excessive
water
and i believe this is the issue that
caused kanye west's mother's death was
like excessive water in her body during
surgery
but that can kill you and it can also
if it's off from for example drinking
alcohol and actually i think the now
that i think of it the name of the video
was like
if you're
uh you know drinking how do you recover
quickly from that and another
interesting tidbit that i didn't know
maybe you knew this was like 10 of the
population gets a dopamine rush from
alcohol
and the rest don't what yeah how do you
feel when you drink i'm in that ten
percent
makes sense because
like
you you do enjoy drinking right love it
love the stuff
love the sauce
yeah we're talking about brian count was
like oh it's northern europeans i don't
i didn't look into whether or not it's
geographically specific just say it all
right you shocked me
okay you're an irish trunk
but i'm also irish but people in my
family have that like my little brother
definitely somebody who's like
gets more animated and energetic which
would correlate with a dopamine rush
where i'm just like i feel tired you
know i drink it and it's a relaxant for
me um as is for most people but you do
hear about these people like oh man i'm
feeling tired i want to drink and it
energizes me and then i'm going to keep
drinking and stay up all night i'm like
what i actually went to a concert last
night at hollywood bowl and before i
went i was like i could have i'm like i
was feeling tired uh i was like i could
have a cup of coffee i was like you know
what i'll actually have a glass of wine
yeah and that like
gets me up right okay so you got the
gene baby yeah but very interesting
because i always it was always confusing
to me like why like am i missing
something here but that makes sense
and it's enough people it's like 10 out
of 100 right 1 in 10
that
you're going to get that population
who's kind of leading the charge no
let's drink more you know because
there's always that person at the party
he's like like no don't fall asleep
drink more it's like no but that's gonna
make me fall asleep more
it's the circle of blackout nice so
basically what this guy's saying is
electrolyte imbalance after you're
drinking is super important if you feel
dizzy it's not necessarily because of
food
you need electrolytes so have that
whatever the gatorade there's no calorie
gatorade or if you're really in a pinch
take a pinch of salt and put it in a
glass of water and drink that salt water
then throw up and then take that throw
up and then drink it again because you
don't want to waste any salt back in the
1600s it was a precious precious
resource so thank your ancestors
hella psychological we already talked
about didn't we or not oh my god we
almost ran out of time basically what
i'm saying is
we did not talk about it tom cruise is
vindicated regarding
ssris and depression
he went viral
back in ought five
for talking about
uh antidepressants
also adhd medication ritalin and
adderall
uh to matt lara on what was it the today
show or good morning america whatever
he was on before he installed that uh
sexual assault button in his office and
got fired oops
it was the oops button oops you're
trapped in my office now
so he
you
what was interesting is you remember
that rant right
uh tom cruise on it's not the couch
jumping one like it was around around
the same time probably but he was like i
know the history of psychiatry you don't
oh yeah yeah it was framed in a way it
was interesting to watch the full clip
again because
there's a part that cut out
and actually if we could start at the
three minute mark there
i'm only asking isn't there a
possibility that do you examine the
possibility that these things do work
for somebody brittle in a natural yes
there are abuses and yes maybe they've
gone too far in certain areas maybe
there are too many kids on riddle and
maybe electric shock your kids aren't
really exactly i'm just saying but but
aren't there examples where it works
you're glad you don't even know what
ritalin is if you start talking about
chemical imbalance you have to evaluate
and read the research papers on how they
came up with these theories matt okay
that's what i've done
then you go and you say where's where's
the medical test where's the blood test
that says how much riddling you're
supposed to get
it's very impressive to listen to you
because clearly you've done the homework
and and you know the subject and you
should and you should do that also
because just knowing people who are on
ritalin isn't enough you should be a
little bit more responsible in knowing
i'm really describing ritalin tom and
i'm not asking anyone else to do you are
saying i know some people who seem to
have been helping but you're saying but
it's like this is a very important issue
this is a very you know what and you're
you're here on the today show right and
to talk about it in a way of saying well
isn't it okay in being reasonable about
it when you don't know and i do
i think that you should be a little bit
more responsible in knowing what it is
because you you communicate to people
but you're now telling me that your
experiences with the people i know which
are zero
are more important than my experiences
what do you mean by that you're telling
me what's worked for people i know or
hasn't worked for people or i know and
i'm telling you i've lived with these
people
and they're better i think we could stop
it there that's also an important
logical point because i don't think matt
lara's hitting the nail on the head
there it would seem like it's logical to
say that but in reality what tom is
saying is that your anecdotal evidence
to suggest that
the broader point that we should
prescribe ritalin to children is true
isn't valid and then he's saying are you
saying that you know what these people
no no it doesn't matter if the people
who are taking it feel that it works
he's making a broader point about
ritalin or ssris both have to do with
the theory that you know adhd is caused
by dopamine deficit or dopaminergic
system deficit and depression is caused
by a serotonergic
system deficit in some capacity right
that theory has nothing to do the
validity of that theory has nothing to
do with i took ritalin or i took ssris
and i feel better right and that's
essentially what matt lauer is saying
that whole portion didn't seem to appear
when you first heard it it was sort of
like the aggressive confrontational
you know
sound bites of tom cruise going
you know i'm right you're wrong he
seemed really hostilely aggressive and
at the time was really framed like oh my
god tom cruise is a psycho
it just seems to make a lot of sense
looking back now he's making some really
good points which is
um
you know vindicated by the research that
has come out
which says essentially that there's no
evidence that depression is caused by
deficit and serotonin now that doesn't
change the fact that ssris work or can
help certain people but they can also
undermine the case for a lot of people
as we covered before
ssris can also interfere there's a quote
here this is where antidepressants
evolve dopamine as well as serotonin as
well as serotonin signaling researchers
have discovered that antidepressant
drugs such as prozac not only affect
levels of the neurotransmitter serotonin
in the brain but also hijack dopamine
signaling as well causing it to launch
serotonin signals so
for example if you're addicted to
something
like gambling
or drugs or porn or whatever that would
be part of your dopaminergic signaling
and a source of enjoyment however
fleeting if you started taking ssris
and it hijacked those feelings you might
feel more depressed because you're like
oh the only things that i you know porn
was my only escape weed was my only
escape those things are less enjoyable
now
in the gap between where you start
taking them and that kicks in and you
start to get new neurons
which is the whole point really long
term of ssris
there can be this space where people end
up getting worse and maybe kill
themselves not the case with psilocybin
mushrooms for example we've covered this
before because they start creating new
neurons right off the bat but
science come out said that and also
johan hari i believe i've mentioned on
this podcast before
also on joe rogan experience and ted
talks he talks about how
the chemical hooks model and similar to
this like chemical imbalance the
chemical imbalance in your brain model
is sort of debunked right there's so
much more to it there's so much more to
happiness well being
depression addiction all these things
community purpose
you know
self-esteem
how do you get self-esteem by doing
things by working out by doing
esteemable acts and doing things that
you yourself can look at in the mirror
and go yes
i'm a good person yes
i can do things yes i got my ass off the
couch and now i feel better and that
gives me more confidence and then i'm
making more social connections and
creating community and all of a sudden
you're happy right it's never going to
come from a pill
but we have been sold that mean based on
the chemical imbalance model okay
can we just look at a few this is why we
can't have any gems oh yes here we go
this dude's doing one of these things
where
he's like
doing the deadlift and the squat at the
same time and just gets wrecked by the
safety bar squad taking them down what i
like about this is you always see these
and the guys only post it when it goes
well i'm glad we're showing that this is
a stupid idea
because these are pointless lists except
to get social media content and also
this guy isn't muscular he should be
focusing on actually gaining muscle and
doing some serious lifts in the gym
learning how to actually squat and
actually deadlift because clearly
uh
he's very skinny so i you know it's like
proof is in the pudding hey maybe before
you try to safety bar squat and dead
lift at the same time with the 10-pound
plate around your neck on a chain
learn to do all those things
individually correctly first huh crazy
concept
next up we got this dude he's trying to
lock out with that shoulder press
overhead
and i know that feeling right when
you're right here for some reason
overhead press more so than bench or
other lifts like that lockout
can really
tie up a lot of that blood
um and make you light-headed and i've
almost passed up but i pride myself on
knowing hey you're about to pass the
threshold from which you cannot return
from and this stupid
you know one rep max on overhead press
in the gym you know that's not for any
sort of competition it's not like you're
at the illustrious crossfit games about
to win the gold um
just drop the weight maybe don't do it
you know if you're sitting there for
seven seconds trying to lock out you're
not gonna get it you know so you're
gonna die because you're standing you
have a weight in your hands and you're
gonna hit the concrete
or even the
sort of hard floor of the gym
and break your neck
what's the next one
yeah so this dude
he's got like four and a half plates on
there it comes down
and the pants split so it asks the age
old questions
when you're in the gym is it more
embarrassing to rip a fart or rip your
pants open
you know what's cool if you if you rip a
fart you can blame it on someone else
you can't like rip your pants open and
say no his pants ripped open
those are john's ass cheeks
this guy's he's going for uh he just did
a clean going for the jerk
this is why you have to get good at
knowing when the weight is
you know what he does what does he do i
think um
makes it harder for him watch his knees
there he locks his knees like inward
like crazy what is going on there
i wasn't like something else going on
before the left hand
[ __ ] out of his knees let's just be
honest he's very unathletic looking you
know yeah but the entire like he just
gets body slammed by this weight
just absolutely clotheslined by it
because when you're going to jerk you're
you you have to bend your knees and then
yeah so what's going on there like he's
like locking him right it's just it
looks all sorts of unathletic i just i
want to see the first part of it like
how did that clean look how did you get
it up there if your knees are that
wobbly and you're dead and athletic but
i've never seen anything like that where
somebody just allows themselves to be
totally bent back because no party like
when you get to here right you're going
get this off me right throw it away
i don't know he also looks like a
teenager but take that
to to note that
olympic lifting is dangerous
be good at it be athletic
or stick to powerlifting like the rest
of the fat nerds okay
you know
the caption here is his little muscular
dog he's a bet his dog benches more than
you
people probably look at him and go oh my
god it's a dangerous little pit bull
he's so muscular he's a frenchie oh is
it frenchie okay just look at him but he
looks like a muscular dog right he's as
strong as [ __ ] the uh
the point
being i look at that and go
i relate to that you know people look at
me in the gym
they see this ugly
muscular person
shaking his hair wildly and go oh yeah
he must be a dangerous [ __ ] but the
truth is
i'm even more awkward than the kid in
the last video
socially speaking not athletically okay
let's uh go on is there that was the
last link but we do have an amazing
as i promised before we are debuting
sketches here this is when i shot hot at
the presses 24 hour fitness here we go
let's play
a lot of people ask me mark do you have
to be thick with three c's to rock into
fake boy merch dropping today well the
answer is you can be any shape or size
as long as you're fixed somewhere
state chubby kings especially where it
counts
stay warm
two
and three
and
a four
and
a five
[Music]
boom did it
so that was uh-huh i said nice it was
pretty good right pretty really good and
um i don't know if you got it but like
it was a dick joke that's what i was
gonna ask
you